GREAT STATE OF FLORIDA.
>> Sean: JOINING US NOW WITH
REACTION, HOUSE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE RANKING MEMBER
CONGRESSMAN DOUG COLLINGS.
WHO APPOINTS THE SENATOR WHO
REPLACED JOHNNY ISAKSON AND WHO
I HAVE KNOWN FOR MANY YEARS,
CONGRESSMAN, BEFORE I GET TO
THIS?
>> THAT WOULD BE THE GOVERNOR OF
THE STATE OF GEORGIA.
>> Sean: I WOULD LIKE THE
GOVERNOR TO APPOINT YOU.
YOU HAVE TURNED INTO A
ROCK STAR.
A REPUBLICAN WITH A BACKBONE, A
REPUBLICAN THAT -- YOU WENT OUT
THERE AND YOU RELEASED
TRANSCRIPTS, AND NO OTHER
CONGRESSMEN WOULD RELEASE.
THAT IS A LEADERSHIP THAT WE
NEED IN THE SENATE.
I WOULD URGE THE GOVERNOR TO
APPOINT YOU.
I THINK YOU WOULD DO A GREAT
JOB.
I HOPE THAT HAPPENS.
WOULD YOU TAKE IT IF OFFERED?
>> YES, SEAN, I WOULD.
WE CAN OFFER A GREAT ABILITY,
BUT BE THERE FOR THE PRESIDENT
AND FIGHT BACK FOR WHAT THE
DEMOCRATIC FORCE HAS BEEN ALL
YEAR.
WE ARE WELL-SUITED FOR THAT.
I APPRECIATE YOUR ENDORSEMENT.
>> Sean: YOU HAVE BEEN A
RISING STAR.
THERE ARE A FEW VERSES THAT HAVE
EMERGED IN THE MADNESS.
YOU ARE ONE OF THEM.
AND I UP MY OR YOUR COURAGE.
LET'S TALK ABOUT WHAT WE HAVE
HEARD HERE.
I'VE NEVER SEEN A PRESIDENT GO
THROUGH THIS.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE DONE NOTHING
TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE IN THREE
YEARS EXCEPT HATE THIS
PRESIDENT.
WHERE DOES THIS GO IN YOUR
OPINION?
>> WELL, IT IS NOW TIME FOR
JERRY NADLER TO MAKE CHICKEN
SALAD OUT OF A SCHIFF SHOW.
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT WILL HAVE
IMPAIRED WHAT THEY WOULD HAVE TO
DO IS TAKE PRESUMPTION, THEY
WOULD HAVE TO TAKE HEARSAY, THEY
WOULD HAVE TO TAKE NOTHING UP
RIGHT WIN QUID PRO QUO, NOTHING
THE PRESIDENT DID WRONG, YOU
MAKE IT INTO A VIABLE ARTICLE OF
IMPEACHMENT TO SHOW THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE THAT HE HAS DONE
SOMETHING WRONG.
BUT YOU KNOW HOW I KNOW THEY
DON'T HAVE ANYTHING?
THE NEXT HEARING THEY ARE GOING
TO BRING ACADEMICS INTO TELL US
WHAT AN IMPEACHABLE OFFENSES.
I WILL TELL YOU WHAT AN
IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE IS NOT,
EVERYTHING THAT WE HAVE SEEN
FROM ADAM SCHIFF AND THE
DEMOCRATS FOR THE PAST YEAR AS
THEY HAVE ATTACKED A VERY
SUCCESSFUL PRESIDENT WHO IS
SIMPLY DOING THE BEST JOB HE CAN
FOR AMERICA.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE ARE GOING TO
START.
NEXT WEEK, GET READY.
I'VE SAID THIS BEFORE, JUDICIARY
SHOW, THE LIGHTS ARE GOING TO
COME ON, GET THE POPCORN READY.
IT'S TIME TO GET DOWN TO
BUSINESS TO SHOW WHAT THE SCHIFF
SHOW LOOKS LIKE IN PERSON.
>> Sean: MAYBE SOME PEOPLE
DON'T LIKE THE PRESIDENTS STYLE
BECAUSE HE FIGHTS.
BUT HE FOUGHT TO GET THE BIGGEST
TAX CUTS IN HISTORY AND GET RID
OF MORE BUREAUCRACY THAN ANY
OTHER PRESIDENT IN THE LAST 100
YEARS.
AND HE FOUND A WAY TO GET THE
BORDER WALL MONEY.
AND HE KEPT HIS PROMISE ON
JUDGES AND TRADE DEALS, AND LOOK
AT THE ECONOMY.
WHO DO YOU THINK GETS IT ON THE
DEMOCRATIC SIDE?
AND DO YOU THINK DEMOCRATS ARE
IN A PANIC?
ARE THEY TELLING YOU SECRETLY
ANYTHING ABOUT HOW THEY REALLY
FEEL?
>> THEY ARE.
I'M LISTENING TO SEVERAL
DEMOCRATS PREGNANT I AM WORKING
WITH DEMOCRATS.
HERE'S SOMETHING INTERESTING.
AT THE HEARING WE WILL HAVE NEXT
WEEK, IT IS SUPPOSED TO BE THE
FIRST OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
PRESIDENT TO ACTUALLY BE ABLE TO
MOUNT ANY KIND OF DEFENSE AS FAR
AS ANSWERING QUESTIONS.
BUT THERE IS NO REASON FOR THE
PRESIDENT'S ATTORNEY, FRANKLY,
TO BE A PART OF THE ACADEMICS.
WHAT THEY BELIEVE IN THE
CONSTITUTION SAYS.
THIS IS AN ABDICATION BY
JERRY NADLER WHO HAS BECOME
BASICALLY A FIGUREHEAD FOR
NANCY PELOSI AND ADAM SCHIFF TO
TELL THEM WHAT TO DO.
AND THAT'S WHAT IS GOING TO
HAPPEN NEXT WEEK.
WELL, WE HAVE TO HAVE, NUMBER
ONE, ADAM SCHIFF HAS TO TESTIFY
PRETTY CLAIM TO BE A SPECIAL
COUNSEL, PROSECUTOR LIKE KEN
STARR.
IF KEN STARR CAN COME BECOME
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE AND TAKE
QUESTIONS, LET'S SEE IF
ADAM SCHIFF CAN.
MAYBE HE CAN DO BETTER WITHOUT
THE GAVEL IN HIS HAND TELLING
THE TRUTH AND BE TRUTHFUL TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ABOUT WHAT HIS
INVOLVEMENT WAS IN THE WHOLE
THING AND WHERE IS GOING TO GO
WITH HIS PLAN PAIRED BUT WE ARE
MEMBERS ON THE COMMITTEE THAT
ARE COMING FORWARD AND SAYING,
AND IF WE DON'T MAKE THIS FAIR,
IF WE DON'T LET THE PRESIDENT
HAVE A DEFENSE AND RAM THIS
THROUGH, THEN THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ARE SEEN THROUGH IT.
SEAN, YOU BROUGHT IT UP TONIGHT,
WE HAVE MEMBERS WHO HAD THE
AUDACITY TO SAY THAT WE SHOULD
DO SOMETHING WITH THE
IMPEACHMENT ON THE DEMOCRATIC
SIDE, BUT REALLY I GUESS GOT
PRESSURED INTO SUBMISSION TO
SAY, NO, I DID NOT RELEASE MEAN
THAT WE HAVE TWO IMPEACHED HIM,
THIS IS HOW SAD THEY ARE COMING
INTO THINGS GIVING?
>> Sean: I A TWO OF THE BEST
YEARS OF MY LIFE LIVING IN THE
STATE OF GEORGIA.
I WAS THE MC THE NIGHT THAT
NEWT GINGRICH BECAME SPEAKER THE
HOUSE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR FIGHT.
YOU ARE OUT THERE.
I HOPE REPUBLICANS ARE LEARNING